hi there reject ease
hi I'm Greg e I'm Johnny
we're gonna watch today the official
announcement trailer for a video game
called Dead Island I know that this
video already has comments of work you
to dude dude let me explain before you
type that nonsense down there we have a
patreon so I know patreon one of our top
reward tiers whatever video you request
we must definitely do and put up on the
youtubes and today comes from a man
named low heat but near Shae I forgot
how to say his name already and he's
correcting me several times so he we
actually covered a short film that he
did in reaction I which was really good
surprisingly very good and he said that
one of his inspirations comes from this
trailer specifically I was like well I
thought this game already came out it
did I was reminded that like I did a
reaction on four years ago to Dead
Island to the trailer that game isn't
like development hell right now I might
not ever come out even though they have
a developer and they said back in July -
he's still gonna come out he wanted us
to check this out regardless whether or
not we're into this game because he was
saying this cinematic trailer is such a
different type of product compared to
the actual game oh boy and also that
this trailer did cause some controversy
that even if you don't play the game
that it's still worthwhile trailer and
I've never I don't never seen the Dead
Island part 1 announcement trailer also
the Dead Island 2 1 trailer I played a
bit of this game at convention ones but
other than that yeah I don't think that
will inform this experience at all maybe
18 see what all the hypes about low heat
low hit Tecla
oh my
oh man
[Music]
oh my Oh No
oh man
oh cool
[Applause]
[Music]
a triple
haha
[Music]
Oh
well
oh ho ho
[Music]
Wow what did you want to play that game
now
yeah and spend all those heartfelt
moments in slow motion racing toward
each other together that's a true that
sticks to the Mac as low heats did have
a short film he did have that like
reverse effect going on throughout well
yeah you're picking up two different
points of view kind of converging at a
middle yeah section yeah and I like that
that was neat the unveiling process of
this trailer is really cool because the
little girls on the ground you think oh
she was just killed right there and then
you might know how if she was biting
someone oh was her dad she was by like
that there's a lot of cool unveiling
happening in this trailer uh yeah yeah
sure really tell me much about the game
other than its another you know zombie
game but in terms of like a short film
like that was a cool short feel I I
totally get why you said like even if
you don't play the game is a worthwhile
trailer it is like watching a short
story oh yeah any time anybody asks like
what's it what's a particularly great
tease for something like this is
probably one of those things is gonna
come to mind I often wonder what gamers
must think of trailers like this cuz I
sit here wondering like aside from just
getting people hyped about your game
what is the actual like mo behind a
trailer like yeah what is it what does
it do for the true for the game yeah cuz
for me I would see that trailer and
think okay is this gonna be like a more
like Last of Us kind of thing where you
know I get the sense that's a little
more spaced out a little more character
driven game and not just like I have a
come-up kind of experience where it's
just gonna be like zombie zombie zombie
after you know one after the other John
look I want to do a little experiment
here mm-hmm
I'm gonna put this in Reverse haha a
movie let's watch that version just to
see how that plays cuz I'm kind of
curious enough like I just kept watching
it going have they made this they just
do it first then I know there's one
sequence of something moving in Reverse
it's the one where she's crawling away
from the zombies and everything I'm
weirdly fascinated to find out like how
it plays yeah I would have to imagine
that it almost would work either
direction
just the reveals probably bigger this
way yeah and that's all part of the
reveal but it's still probably like
heartbreaking and beautiful little sappy
indie
yeah family like I could have put that
together yeah I actually could have done
without the ending bit over the family
I'm like you need to like drive it home
I know it's sad I could tell it's their
daughter yeah and even if it's not no
this is a little girl it's still yeah
headphones on John the audio is gonna be
funky - that's gonna be cool
I'll probably add some atmosphere in a
different
I hate words
[Music]
it works yeah
so what is this gonna get like messed up
[Music]
[Applause]
I think then reverse music actually
makes it kind of cool it because it
gives it this otherworldly this extra
otherworldly quality death
it literally flipped everything else
right
[Music]
I swear I was gonna be ad North in the
movie
some ways is kind of more hurry
I feel like I did before by putting this
in reverse but I have do anything
you had the idea she's gonna be played
by Adam Jenna alone or Morena Baccarin
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
it's kind of cool actually they actually
get a good similar of a different effect
here
[Music]
the reverse music does skip like her
life is flashing for ya
[Music]
yeah it's like her life is flashing
before her eyes if you watch it like
this final moments hey both versions are
cool right Techland the game what what
is this game called I'm glad for whoever
got to put their creative stamp on that
cuz clearly they've outlived that game
what if we put this well yeah I also
like do they pull this is from an actual
cutscene or did they just animate a
bunch of stuff specifically for this
trailer that's what I mean like well did
you just give away the plot cuz the dad
clearly got bit yet to actually play
that game hey that was a cool trend that
chosen to stick with me especially now
that I put it in Reverse for the trailer
now you know it backwards and forwards
yes I do
guys though he has an awesome short film
called retreat horror short film we did
do a reaction - you could watch it on
his channel called another view all the
way in Canada we're only nice people are
so low he thank you so much buddy
Thanksgiving you guys apparently saw
bread that like in September or October
it's a really weird Happy Holidays to
you bud and I'm so happy you're part of
the patron page you've been quite Louis
for a long time now and I Love You Man
thank you so much and I think all right
guys well you can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
Bell and hey check us on patreon we got
TV show reaction watch along as John
does music video coverage and we got
weekly Q&A s we love to have you come up
a project today